the only way to not go crazy trying to
handle responsive images is to set up an
image pipeline that makes it easy for
you to create multiple versions of your
images automatically
and to do that you're going to need the
right software for your own sanity i
want you to take a step back and install
grunt
image optim and image magic
seriously grunt is super useful i use it
all the time to automate tasks for my
projects
image optim and image magic are also
awesome because it makes it so easy to
convert images to different sizes
formats and compression levels
you're going to want their help when you
start working on the project for this
course and in your future projects
you'll find links in the instructor
notes for some how-to guides
once you've got everything installed
check this box to continue